if you are creating a short list of
luminaries in the field of Public Health
you wouldn't think that someone named
Michelle Lujan Grisham would appear on
that list at no point in her life did
Grisham receive any training in medicine
or science instead she has a Bachelor of
Arts degree in something called
university studies and for the
uninitiated a degree in university
studies is what people get when they
when they don't want to study in a
university then Grisham earned a law
degree which of course also has nothing
to do with public health and afterwards
for several years Grisham worked at a
state department dealing with aging and
long-term services and she eventually
directed that same Department those were
Michelle Lujan grisham's credentials
when in 2004 she became the highest
ranking Public Health official in the
state of New Mexico presumably the fact
that you came from a prominent political
family in the state didn't hurt her
chances of getting the job but whatever
the case grisham's tenure as the state's
Secretary of Health was unremarkable she
only had the post for a couple of years
before moving on but many years later
later in 2020 the incoming Biden
Administration took a very close look at
Michelle Lujan Grisham for reasons that
remain unknown the Biden Administration
apparently believed that grisham's
limited experience experience in the
field of Public Health from more than a
decade ago qualified her to run the
Department of Health and Human Services
at the federal level this is the
department that oversees all public
health issues in the entire country
Biden's aides publicly courted her for
the job they said that she was under
careful consideration ultimately though
Grisham decided to remain as governor of
New Mexico so she didn't want the job
now in that capacity from the beginning
Grisham has governed less like a
politician and more like a public health
bureaucrat with Limitless power for the
past three years Gresham has ruled the
state under an indefinite public health
emergency
protocols recently as late last year
when most of the country had moved on
from covid Grisham was issuing orders
requiring that state workers and
hospital employees wear masks and take a
regular schedule of covid shots
Grisham often cited experts like herself
to justify these unlawful and
increasingly untenable mandates
but by March of this year the people of
New Mexico finally had enough you know
Grisham lacking the political will to
sustain yet another extension of her
Public Health Powers formally ended the
covid-19 emergency in the state now
it took long enough but grisham's
authority to issue unilateral edicts was
finally gone at that point
now put yourself in Michelle Lujan
grisham's position at that very moment
how would you handle the reality that
you can no longer rule your state like a
dictator
now if you're a well-adjusted person who
cares about your constitutional oath of
office you'd probably be thankful that
the emergency is over even if it was
fake to begin with
you wouldn't want to assert arbitrary
extra legal powers
well some to say that that was not
Michelle grisham's reaction instead she
immediately began ruminating about other
ways that she could expand her emergency
powers in May in a conversation that
didn't receive any attention from the
media Grisham spoke to Johns Hopkins
University's School of Public Health
about her plan to expand the field of
quote-unquote Public Health to encompass
everything every imaginable policy issue
would fall under public health and she
she announced this publicly
this is footage that should have set off
a lot of alarm Bells but nobody even
noticed it or talked about it here it is
watch
everything is a public health issue gun
violence is a public health issue
poverty is a public health issue
environmental consequences from energy
is a public health issue all of these
disenfranced uh chives populations all
of the equity barriers are all public
health issues and when we address those
our economy is better our families are
stronger our risks are fewer
if we want to save the planet
and we want to make families independent
we want to eradicate poverty and
Injustice it's going to take a whole new
class of young dedicated professionals
we're ready to tick on the mantle so I'm
thrilled that they're watching and
listening and I'm ready to have you work
in New Mexico and there are many other
States including your own home States
deserve you and need you let's go fix
the world
everything is a public health issue says
Michelle Lujan Grisham she says poverty
climate change gun violence all public
health
let's go fix the world Grisham says as
the Johns Hopkins lady uh sitting there
public health lady nods and grins along
yes let's fix the world that's something
we can do let's fix it
now you might be wondering when it
became the goal of the public health
industry to quote fix the world
wasn't there gigs supposed to be to you
know just to make sure the public is
healthy Public Health make sure the
public is healthy that's what I assumed
not anymore apparently in fact that
hasn't been the goal since covet you
might remember it was a it was a Johns
Hopkins public health expert quote
unquote named Jennifer nuzo who stated
that it's a bad idea to Riot during the
public during the covet pandemic unless
you're rioting for George Floyd and BLM
which case go for it
so public health is not the goal anymore
now the goal is to pursue social justice
which is what they mean when they talk
about fixing the world
now the goal is to correct every problem
with the world and the people who
identify the problems are Governor
Grisham and other left-wing bureaucrats
like her
now you can think of a variety of terms
to describe what's going on here Mission
creep comes to mind
it's also incoherent because if every
problem is a public health problem then
Public Health has outlived its
usefulness as a distinct category
because it's not a distinct category if
everything is a public health issue then
nothing is a public health issue
whatever you call this phenomenon we're
seeing it's obvious what Grisham is
doing and why she's doing it
like the rest of the public health
establishment she has realized that she
can assume totalitarian Powers as long
as she can claim that she's addressing
some Public Health matter
the solution is to label everything a
public health matter and then she can do
whatever she wants
and if she manages to get away with that
then she gets to control everything
that was her approach and she said it
out loud in front of a friendly audience
back in may not even trying to hide it
well it's clear to the left is giving up
their morals and any Common Sense
there's no better time to build a habit
of daily prayer meditation building a
habit of prayer can help you cultivate
an attitude of gratitude focusing on
what you are thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being hallow is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the U.S it
helped me maintain a daily prayer
routine can help you do the same
download the app for free at hollow.com
Matt Walsh you can set prayer reminders
and track your progress along the way
not sure where to start we'll check out
father Mike schmitz's Bible in a year
podcast available on the hollow app or
pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel even some world-class athletes
with Halo you can customize a personal
prayer plan that works for you listen
wherever you are with downloadable
offline sessions using hello to connect
with others who share your beliefs and
values can provide a sense of belonging
support and Foster a sense of community
as well ultimately we'll learn how we
can become better individuals in spite
of today's broken world as we strive to
become more like Christ in our daily
lives through prayer fasting and giving
download hello.com Matt Walsh you get an
exclusive three months free that's three
months absolutely free at hello.com Matt
Walsh
a couple of days ago as you may have
seen Grisham put the next stage of her
plan into motion she announced a public
health order quote unquote that
prohibits residents in so-called high
crime areas including New Mexico's
biggest city from possessing firearms
outside of their homes
and in making this announcement
Christian Grisham admits that criminals
are not going to follow the law okay the
people that are actually
committing the gun crime they're not
going to follow this she admits that
she also acknowledges that she's
probably going to get overturned in the
courts because she doesn't really have
the Constitutional authority to do this
but she doesn't care
watch
but your point is valid to the
Constitution isn't it unconstitutional
to say you cannot exercise your carry a
license with one exception and that is
if there's an emergency and I've
declared an emergency for a temporary
amount of time I can invoke additional
Powers no constitutional right in my
view including my oath
is intended to be absolute there are
restrictions on Free Speech there are
restrictions on my freedoms in this
emergency
this 11 year old and all these parents
who have lost all these children they
deserve my attention to have the debate
about whether or not in an emergency we
can create a safer environment because
what about their constitutional rights I
took an oath to uphold those two and if
we ignore this growing problem without
being bold I've said to every other New
Mexican your rights are subrogated to
theirs and they are not in My
Views there are already laws against the
crime so I got it but but again if I'm
unsafe
who's standing up for that right
if this climate is so out of control
somebody should do something
I'm doing as much as I know to do
do you really think that criminals are
going to hear this message and not carry
a gun in Albuquerque on the streets for
30 days uh no
but here's what I do think it's a pretty
resounding message
somebody should do something someone
should do something she says that has
been the justification for pretty much
every tyrannical power grab uh in recent
history it's always under the guise of
just do something that was all of covid
right it was just do it doesn't matter
what we're doing but we're scared so
just do something something
and she's doing something
will it achieve anything at all I mean
before we get to the question of whether
she has the authority to do it she
doesn't
will it even achieve anything
even according to her
she seems skeptical of that but she says
that it sends a resounding message
she's not even pretending that there's
any legal Merit to this she doesn't even
suggest that criminals will will obey it
it's all about the message
well what is that message exactly
superficially what Grisham is saying is
that no right is absolute in her words
and you know that part of it just
isolated on its own no right is absolute
that's basically true of course that's
why there's a legal process for removing
rights if you are a convicted murderer
you lose your right to carry a gun for
example and most people have no issue
with that certainly everyone agrees that
you can't bring your gun with you into
prison when you go into prison you lose
basically all of your constitutional
rights or most of them
and most people again have no issue with
that
the problem is that Grisham is
attempting to strip everyone's basic
constitutional rights all at once by The
Stroke of a pen
basically treating everyone in the city
like they are convicted murderers
and her reasoning to justify that
dramatic expansion of her Authority is
ludicrous
I mean there's always been gun crime
what exactly makes it a special
emergency now
In that clip you heard Grisham allude to
something approaching an explanation at
least in her view she says that an 11
year old child was just shot and killed
in a road rage uh incident near a
baseball stadium in Albuquerque which is
a terrible travesty of course someone
shot 17 times at a moving vehicle
killing the child and critically
injuring a woman inside the car
therefore Grisham says because of this
emotionally charged episode we need to
punish every law-abiding gun owner in
the entire state or at least in that
City and maybe eventually the entire
state
we need to turn them all into criminals
or treat them like they are
now if if road rage is the issue then
you think that she would ban cars
I mean you could say that well that
never would have happened if uh not for
guns never would have happened without
cars
but I guess she doesn't think that she
can get away with Banning cars yet so
she's settling just for the guns
interestingly enough Grisham doesn't
display any curiosity about the
assailant in that shooting
at the moment that Grisham issued the
that order ending the Second Amendment
in New Mexico because this 11 year old
was killed authorities didn't know the
identity of the suspect they didn't know
anything about it
they didn't know a single thing about
him that's more than a little strange if
you think about it you have to wonder
wonder what kind of person shoots a
moving vehicle 17 times due to road rage
are we talking about a law-abiding uh
you know a gun owner is that what we're
talking about
it's possible
or are we talking about somebody with a
criminal history perhaps maybe somebody
on probation
could it be that we're not even talking
about an American citizen at all
those are questions that Grisham very
badly doesn't want you to think about
but they're reasonable questions
especially if you're familiar with the
numbers on on how many felons and
illegal aliens are shooting up the
streets of New Mexico right now there's
a lot of them
and thanks in large part to policies
that Grisham and her fellow Democrats
have enacted
nearly half of all federal crimes in the
entire country are committed in States
like New Mexico that sit along the
Mexican border and there's a reason for
that it's not a coincidence the reason
is called open borders
but Democrats in the state haven't done
anything about it in fact during the
Trump Administration Gresham refused to
call the Border crisis an emergency
so that is not an emergency but now the
Second Amendment is an emergency
and it's not the criminals Interstate
who are shooting people they're not the
emergency it's the second amendment
itself
so where is this leading exactly
again Grisham knows her order is going
to get overturned eventually which is
probably why she limits it to 30 days
she's hoping the courts will take longer
than 30 days to strike this down so
what's the real agenda here is this
order just a trial balloon to introduce
this idea to the public so that down the
line these kinds of emergency orders are
more palatable
reading between the lines you can see
that the Democratic party uh probably
views it that way
following grisham's order to the
surprise of many conservatives
Democratic senator Ted Liu along with
the deeply neurotic anti-gun Harvard kid
David Hogg came out and actually
criticized the order as unconstitutional
and they used almost precisely the same
language which tells you that a memo
went out somewhere to coordinate
left-wing messaging on this topic so
here's what Lou wrote quote I support
gun safety laws however no state in the
Union can suspend the Federal
Constitution there is no such thing as a
state public health emergency exception
to the U.S Constitution
Hall grow basically the same thing quote
I support gun safety but there's no such
thing as a state public health emergency
exception to the U.S Constitution
now first of all notice how creepy it is
that a Harvard brat and a U.S senator
are sourcing their talking points from
the same mysterious higher power and we
know that these are talking points
they're saying exactly the same thing
those posts did not come from Ted Lou's
office or the brilliant mind of David
Hogg they probably came from the DNC
which is providing messaging on how to
handle this
and for that reason it's it's worth
parsing the messages very carefully
both messages say that there's no State
exception to the US Constitution that
allows for public health emergencies to
supersede constitutional rights and that
sounds good
but of course it doesn't go far enough
not even close
there's a reason they say State because
they're deliberately leaving open the
possibility that the federal government
might be able to step in and create such
Public Health exemptions the
constitutional rights
they're reserving that power for
congress at some point in the future
even as they say that states can't do it
on their own
that's a big deal because if you think
back to covid some of the biggest
infringements on civil liberties came
from the federal government's assertion
of emergency Powers the CDC we all
forget nationalize the country's rental
properties
unilaterally on their own they did this
they made it illegal for landlords to
evict tenants even if the tenants
weren't paying rent
nothing like that has ever happened in
this country before but a so-called
public health agency did it on their own
and of course the buy Administration
fired service members who didn't take
the shot in fact they tried to have more
than 100 million workers and private
companies fired unless they took the
shot or submitted to a regular covet
testing over and over again
the FED set the blueprint for covet
totalitarianism and the states followed
so is that what they're planning for the
next emergency
quote unquote will the federal
government attempt to use emergency
powers to supersede the Second Amendment
as they superseded all of our rights
during covet
now for the moment thankfully it doesn't
appear that this attempt to unilaterally
end the Second Amendment in New Mexico
will succeed for one thing several law
enforcement officials in New Mexico have
already come out and said they're not
going to enforce the order and yesterday
as journalist Ford Fisher documented
protesters many of them openly carrying
showed up in Albuquerque and the police
didn't do anything about it
and on one hand this is obviously
encouraging it shows why we have the
second amendment in the first place it's
a self-reinforcing Amendment essentially
when everybody's armed it's awfully
difficult for police to disarm everyone
without violence and that's violence
that no politician wants to be
responsible for at least not yet
but at the same time this is all still
profoundly distressing
it shouldn't fall on American citizens
to go out in public and risk arrest or
civil penalties or Worse to enjoy a
constitutional right
the simple fact that this kind of
demonstration is even necessary is a
huge win for the left
this is a win for the partisans who want
to chip away at our constitutional
rights bit by bit until they're gone
and we know that because Grisham the
governor
should be in prison right now she is
conspiring to undermine the federal
rights of American citizens which
according to the president set by the
Trump prosecutions is supposed to be a
very serious crime
and unlike Trump Grisham is openly
admitting that she intends to subvert
Americans constitutional rights she's
admitting it in fact as of last night
Gresham was openly bragging about all
this on Twitter so so why isn't every
D.A in New Mexico bringing charges
against Grisham tonight why why aren't
the uh where are the RICO charges
where are the raids on her mansion
why isn't she being frog marched down
the street in handcuffs
why aren't they trying to throw her in
prison for the rest of her life
that's what she deserves
it's what the left would obviously do if
she was on the other side imagine if a
republican Governor tried to I don't
know
um unilaterally suspend the 19th
Amendment arguing that Women Voters are
a threat to the country in our way of
life
how do we think Democrats would respond
to that
no they'd be saying bring the federal
government and put that person in jail
right now
remove them from Power today because of
that
that's not what's happening to Gresham
so if this order was a trial balloon the
response from the right has been
woefully insufficient
tyrants have always used emergencies
whether real or imaginary to justify
their power grabs covet was the pivotal
moment when most of the country laid
down
and allowed the government to suspend
essentially all of our rights
for the sake of protecting us against a
cold
career bureaucrats like Governor Grisham
they took note of that
and now she's taking it to the next
level
and she's getting really only minimal
pushback
hard to imagine where this goes next as
we showed you in that video from Johns
Hopkins Grisham herself has already
outlined the plan from here
so we can probably expect a climate
change emergency to justify Banning cars
a transphobia emergency to shut down
non-affirming speech
a racism emergency to Ram through a
federal reparations plan a poverty
emergency to redistribute wealth
the possibilities are endless
and unless Public Health autocrats like
Michelle Lujan Grisham experience real
consequences for what they're doing
then these nation-ending possibilities
will become reality
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
wall show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcasts